these examples can be given in scores
and I do agree with you not that I'm a
fan of Saddam
Hussein neither do I say that Saddam
musin is a practicing Muslim but you
know America attacks Iraq and puts a
sanction
embargo that no medicine no food should
go there because of which more than half
a million children were killed because
of sanction putting sanctions who's to
blame and when they attack Iraq they
don't find any weapons of B destruction
who's to blame I would blame George Bush
it is clear why can't she read between
the lines and she's a woman of the media
or maybe you I don't know why she it's
very evident that even when Saddam
Hussein was arrested he had a trial in
com whether it's just I don't know
irrespective what he has done in Islam
we have to give a fair chance to the
person who is the culprit or the person
who you think is responsible I doubt
whether he have given a free chance fine
I do agree he has done many evils maybe
but surely there was no proof of weapons
of M destruction no proof and has anyone
condemned George Bush fine I know later
on many people did say that he's TIR
number one and when the survey came in
America and throughout the world who is
terrist number one is it Benin ladin is
it Saddam Hussein or is it George Bush
and do you know in all the polls whether
conducted in America or UK or throughout
the world George Bush he sweeped the
polls the lowest he got was
73% and some Wes he got more than 80%
now when people compared Americans
compared who is a terrorist bin ladin
Saddam Hussein or George Bush even in
the BBC poll George Bush sweep the polls
now doesn't bar know about that so very
very
comfortably they take what they want
from the BBC and they don't take what
they don't want and this is not again
publicized it comes on and finish so bar
that there's a woman of the media that
same BBC says that this is the public
opinion has she said come on
[Music]
BBC yes brother the next questions we'll
have brother here
as I learned from you alhamdulillah you
always quote
that they make plan Allah makes plan
Allah is the best of planners so
similarly I feel that the NDTV people
they kept you side and they had given
you less than four minute and to
alhamdulillah less than three and half
three and a
half 3 and a half minute and
alhamdulillah today you come up with
with the same topic and you are saying
alhamdulillah more than one hour so this
is from Allah subhana tala alhamdulillah
as I said that I am the bearded man my
father was not having a beard Mah so
keeping a free will yeah that is what
I'm saying my mother she was not wearing
hijab and I got a five sister
alhamdulillah all they are wearing hijab
you should give toab KH yes that is what
I'm saying to Kabir Khan only my wife is
wearing hijab her mother was not even
wearing hijab so I can Dua to Kabir Khan
inshallah maybe his son will keep the
beard and his daughter will wear the
hijab insh if they watch peace TV inshah
and I pray to Allah that may also give
up here
insh insh so now my question is Zakir B
now one two three four times you've seen
all this uh Channel people okay they
have cheated you I can say that they
have wasted your time so if they will
call you again for any uh program will
you go for them that again depends as I
said I'm not saying I'll never go for
any talk shows again I've been abroad on
talk shows as I say that I try and judge
the integrity and the honesty and the
intention of the person in the show
maybe I judged NDTV earlier when they
had interview of mine which was taken by
Shar Gupta it was wonderful it was par
Excellence why because we didn't edit
anything even even though he may not
have agreed with everything what I said
but he allowed me to speak so therefore
one to one interview is far
superior even there a person who has an
evil intention can alter many things but
Shar Gupta pedor chief of Indian Express
same television Chan NTV so I cannot say
it is NDTV
agenda to malign Muslims it may be the
agenda of the the people show that's for
the people always say that you know so
maybe so depending upon who calls me but
normally after appearing for the show of
Faruk shik on M I always put a condition
especially to the non-islamic channels
that I will get my own camera I will get
my own crew and record some initially
say yes then they say no here they told
no at the last moment so they went a
step further than the other channels
I've been invited by hundreds of talk
shows by many channels again as a policy
I don't attend because it's too much of
time wastage
coming
there and spending us and being allowed
to speak for 3 4 minutes personally
because I already come on the channel if
a learned person who doesn't have
exposure to the media I feel he should
yet go he should go maybe the people get
some hi but here because I come on the
various channels there are hundreds of
millions of viewers it will damage the
information so for me I should be
careful before attend any show but I
cannot I will not attend any in my life
I'll take the precaution but rest I
leave in the hands of Allah as you
rightly said Allah says in Sur Imran
3:54 they plan and plotted Allah to plan
Allah is the best of planners so maybe
because I attended the far shak's
show my
intentions to launch a satellite channel
became more firm that attended before P
was launched you know what I say that
Salman Raji the book he wrote about
satanic
versus is to be condemned net result
many people wanted to read this saic
vers of the Quran and there are
thousands of non-muslims accepted Islam
911 the attack on the Twin Tower is to
be condemned whoever did it is wrong
whether Muslim or non-muslim whether
George Bush bin lad whoever did is wrong
that should be condemned but the net
result whoever did it net result many
people wanted to know what is this
religion about Islam and when I used to
go to the Western Country before 911
there were few non-muslims used to come
for my talk now when I go post 911 there
are more non-muslims attending the talk
so net result is that we have more
apportion to dawa the that was wrong but
the end result Islam is spreading faster
so more the media is maligning Islam we
find that Islam is spreading more so if
they have have more such like these on
the NT I personally have no problem
because Allah is there to take care of
his Dean and his religion and some of
the other at the end of the day it will
surely be benefit for
Islam yes
brother salamu
alaykum Shah ruk Khan sounded a little
apologetic when he said something
somewhere is wrong but we have to uh
adjust and bear with them uh so how far
we should adjust and why should we be
apologetic
that's my question I don't know in which
context are you telling about that and
everyone is talking about shuk
Khan I don't know which context he
mentioned this but yes there are many
people who apologetic I don't know
shahruk Khan was here or not that time
and in what context did you say that we
should adjust but normally what a person
there are people who are many a Time
afraid to keep a beard even if they want
to keep thinking that they can be
victimized
in that context if some people are
getting afraid to keep your bir or wear
a cap that they'll be recognized as
Muslim and they'll be victimized which a
person should not get scared but some
people the tawa may not be that strong
and there are cases where RS take place
in certain countries in certain cities
and if out of fear someone does that so
may Allah forgive them in this case if
somebody chooses certain things and
don't choose depend upon
them yes
brother as alikum My Name Is tanir shik
by profession I'm a
businessman I have got two quick
questions number one is after watching
the program it appeared that uh baradat
and Kabir Khan were trying to promote a
new religion known as the moderate Islam
where everything that Islam permits is
prohibited and everything Islam
prohibits is permitted in this religion
so your opinion about that and number
two I have seen you in many live debates
all over the world uh how how do you
find the experience of a live debate as
compared to a debate on TV
show as far as and Kabir Khan promoting
moderate Muslim that have been answered
in the email very clearly I need not
comment further that when I spoke if you
see the full
debate I was asked only four questions
by and in these four questions I was
interjected by her more than 12 times on
average every question she interjected
twice not allowing me to complete and
Kabir Khan also interjected me twice so
this shows that even if they give me
three and a half minutes if they give
three and a half minutes to me okay
speak for three and a half minutes or
speak one one minute with interjection I
don't mind I don't mind going on a show
speak for 3 minutes saying okay here you
have got three time one one minute and
one time half i' got no problem give me
four times but saying a sentence 20
seconds again interjecting again asking
a second question this is an expertise
of a person who's well vered not that I
wasn't aware but I being on the panel
not the moderate I could not do
anything and same thing when I spoke
something if she didn't interject it was
Kabir Khan so one answer on average four
times once by Kabir Khan and but irres
of what it is I did make my point clear
that Muslim is a person who submits the
will to God it's not submitting the will
to Kabir or
to it's submitting a will to God what's
the will of God read the Quran and Quran
you have to go to if you want to know
what a true Muslim is you have to read
the Quran and follow the Commandments go
to the Hadith and read that's it and any
scholar who say anything if it matches
with Quran and say Hadith you follow
what I say also has got no value in
Islam if what I say matches with the
Quran and you follow it so even if say
something about Islam if it matches with
Quran say you follow if it doesn't match
it you leave it aside as far as the
difference between a live debate
conducted in public and the debate
conducted in a TV
show the difference is that in a life
debate when we have public debate and
you have seen many of the debates that
I've taken part in it's a normal format
is
given each of the two
speakers is given equal amount of time
to speak whether it be half an hour each
or 50 minutes each or one hour each or
both are given chances twice and the
role of the moderators to see to it that
each speaker sticks to the time even
though the topic is given the speaker
can sway from the topic that his will it
is audience who is the judge and the
role of the moderator is to keep the
time and to see to it that the questions
are given equally to both the speakers
both having different views in a TV talk
show it is not like the one we have in
the public when you have a TV talk show
the moderator is here also supposed to
be neutral
which is never the case in a panel
debate the moderator normally is not
neutral R will you find a talk show in
where the moderator is really moderate
means neutral unbiased most of the time
depending upon the agenda of the
moderator or of the producer they can
sway the debate if the two people who
are debating the moderator may give more
time to the view he or she likes
and may give less time there is no eping
like the way we have in a public debate
in this context that is more fair this
is unfair where a lot depends on the
moderator and even on the producer if he
does not like the view of the person who
has won the debate in the post
production he can chop off his answers
in the live debate you cannot so if a
live debate is recorded and shown on the
channel That is far better fine even a
live debate can be edited but since both
the parties have a recording
if someone tries to edit and show a
wrong version the other party also has a
copy here if you tell that I'm coming on
your TV show for a debate let me get my
cameras no one will agree unless the
intention of the moderator
is clear and
correct they will say okay it is you
know it is our show we're doing it for
money we're doing for trp tell them okay
we'll record you keep the give the after
heing after telecasting a show so we
have told that on many channels fine if
you fear that we record we will show it
before you what you do we'll record you
can keep your cassette power cassette
with you once you tel the show give our
original back they will never agree
unless the intention of the moderator or
the producer is nothing but showing the
truth he will allow you but we have
asked in
India more than 100 times when I've been
called for panel discussions or for TV
interviews or for a panel debate that
let us get our cameras initially they
may agree but before the show backed out
so this shows the intention of the
moderator so therefore I prefer having a
public
debate in the public rather than on the
TV show we continue with comments from
some of the websit especially
NDTV the shazaad who says and now we
have more media distortions regarding
Islam Kat is a slick lady simply
brilliant amazing manipulative skills
knows exactly when to interrupt so
nothing Earth shattering is said by the
Learned Dr Zakir n we have ahmedullah
tah saying Bara didn't give time to Dr
NY it was a waste whenever Dr NY started
giving any references she quickly came
in between and stopped him the show was
all about promoting my name is Khan
kurban and people standing against hijab
mansur Ashraf says this was the worst
interview I have ever seen the worst and
the TV has really got it terribly wrong
when you are talking about this issue
you bring srk SOA who have no clue about
Islam and they clearly admitted that and
on the other hand where the logic in
bringing Karan johar this leaves a
really bad taste but mashallah Dr Zakir
gave his best in the limited time he was
given and lastly we have monah Hassan
saying I'm very sad that Dr n wasn't
given much chance to speak and to say
what the correct Islam is all about Dr n
is doing a great job there are so many
millions and millions of people who are
getting benefited by him he inspires
many the question before all of us is
what's the reality behind TV talk
shows the positive
the negative and the in between we throw
open the floor for questions from our
brothers in the audience anyone who
would like to question Dr Zakir most
welcome yes
brother Salam alikum my name is Muhammad
uh actually in the program I noticed
that uh many of the panelists as well as
the anchor they used a term called
Lunatic Fringe have started to represent
Islam uh if they were referring it to
the Muslim Scholars and orators isn't
this a derogatory remark and I would
like to ask one more question that not
only in this program but usually in the
media when these kind of celebrities
like cricketers or film stars
politicians they say that being a good
human being humanity is the most
important aspect of Islam whereas uh I
think that toed is more Superior so I
would like you to comment on this and I
would like Dr Nike to tell all the
Muslims that which is the most important
aspect as far as Islam is concerned as
far as the term lunatic Fring is
concerned in the talk show as far as my
memory goes it was first used by Kabir
Khan and later on it was used by other
panelists including bar and he had a
subtle way what he meant was that the
so-called Scholars of Islam that's what
he meant and it was really hitting Bel
the belt
and yes if it had to be used for
anyone I would say that the vice
Chancellor of jam
Mia it can be used for him because he
had distorted reviews about Islam as far
as what is the most
important point of a Muslim what is the
most important thing for a Muslim people
normally say that it is human values I
don't disagree with it a person should
be a good human being to be a good
Muslim a person cannot be a good Muslim
without being a good human being he has
to be a good human being a human being
is a subset of a good Muslim being a
good human being is a subset of a good
Muslim and what is the most important
thing of being a Muslim as you said the
first pillar of Islam that that is
believing in the on of Allah subhana
tala that's also the most important
thing of a good human being not only of
a Muslim even the most important thing
for a good human being is to thank his
Creator so the most important thing for
a human being and for a Muslim is to
believe in the Oneness of our creat
Allah subhana wa taala and to worship
him and no one else and the opposite the
biggest sin for a Muslim or a biggest
sin for any human being is to worship
somebody else besides almighty God Allah
subhana tala or to associate partners
with the Creator almighty God any
brother
here questions for yes yes
brother Alum Asam my question is that
you were telling about that 911 was an
inside job at that time Bara interrupted
you how can you prove that 911 was an
inside job brother I never said that 911
was inside job I said this is the view
of the people some people believe that
so when barad asked me when she asked me
on Usama bin
ladin and she asked my views on Usama
bin ladin
and I said that I cannot base my views
on BBC and CNN because that's what the
Quran says whenever you get permission
check it up before you pass it on to the
third person so if I have to base my
views on BBC and CNN I have to agree
that was a terrist based on this I said
I cannot give my opinion just on BBC and
CNN and then she goes on to say that
haven't you seen Al jaaz yes I seen But
Al Jaz again according to me it is a
part of the American con
it's controlled by the
Americans I've been to Ala Channel I've
been to Qatar I know many people who are
on high post and many have the opinion
that Al jaaz is contron by the Americans
so why should the tape of Osama bin
ladin be given only to Al jazer why not
to other Muslim channels why
not fine again what I told her that I
have seen even Al jazer but I've even
seen loose chain now Loose Change there
are many documentaries that are
available in America made by the
Americans which prove that 911 was
inside job and I being a man of research
I told her I keep on traveling and I see
the evidence from both the sides now
logically if you see the evidence shown
on BBC and
CNN and shown in Al jazer compared to
what is shown in L Change 911 and
various other documentaries and
especially there was an article that
even came in times of India that there
was 75 American scientist holding top
post in various universities who said
that we cannot agree that 91 could have
been done by few Arabs it's
impossible and we are going to expose
the TRU and they said that this has to
be an inside job who not normal
Americans American scientists and
professors now here you have on one side
American scientists and professors who
are giving their View and here you have
clippings which are shown on Al jazer
which many of them say it is mofed and
as I give an example that those who know
the media well and I give an example
that when they showed the talibans
beating the women one of the experts
said and there was a couple Malayan
couple who have been for a couple of
months in Afghanistan they're doctors
they are normal people husband wife both
of them doctors and many of the people
they said that because they lived with
talibans they know how the talibans wear
the turban and what is shown on these
BBC CNN National Geography it is not the
way the Taliban SL the turban because we
as non-arabs we do not find a difference
in how the Saudi ties is turbine how the
the Kuwaiti TI is turbine or amirati but
these people know there a different
style the Saudi Arab as a turbine the
Kuai Arab as a turbine far it the same
first most of the Chinese look alike but
the Chinese know what the difference
between the different Chinese and the
same thing once it was asked to Y on
rley that what is the view about alqa
now she was there she lived with Taliban
she went to
expose the talibans she went to expose
the evil done by them but when she goes
to Afghanistan she's arrested by the
talibans and when she's arrested she
thinks now she's going to be slaughtered
she's going to be raped and she thinks
this is the last moment of her life but
they surround her and she's wondering
that the last day of the life they
surround her and they are silent and
she's wondering what happened
then after a lot of you know maybe
couple of hours there's a lady who comes
and checks whether she has any weapon
she's so irritated that if you wanted me
to know she puts up her skirts and shows
that she has nothing and all the
talibans turn away they look the other
side so she's saying that to destroy the
talibans even if you send some
undergarments by plane and drop it
they'll be destroyed that means how
modest they are this is said by a
British reporter who goes to a
Afghanistan and later on she realized
that the way they treated her before she
was released she was one condition the
didn't for her they said you promise US
that you'll read the Quran so she said
that once she's relased she read the
Quran only on that condition they left
her they didn't demand anything and when
she was released when the media asked
her what
happened and she said that they treated
me like a
guest after that she was botted from the
media so this shows how the media is B
and has spoken to yley personally she's
the reporter the same way about the
inside job when you see these
documentaries on 911 or loose chain
Loose Change again is a documentary
which gives various evidences why 911
was inside job and time will not permit
me to give all details if you see my
video cassette is Terrorism a Muslim
Monopoly and terrorism in Jihad I spoken
about this just to mention a few they
said that it's not possible that an air
CFT when it collides into the Twin Tower
the Twin Tower can crumble down
immediately the person who constructed
the Twin Tower he said it's not possible
that the fuel of the Aeroplane can melt
the iron bars of the Twin Towers it
requires more than 2,000 degrees and
that's not the degree of the fuel 2,000
de Centigrade it's impossible
immediately within two days the person
who made the statement was sacked
similarly those who spoke against 911
the 75 scientist even they were sent on
a long holiday they was act so when
America speaks about freedom of speech
why do they don't want anyone to speak
against him furthermore they say that if
a plane is going to crash into the Twin
tow surely it's not possible to swirl
the plane with so much accuracy and to
say that a few people did training just
for a couple of months even pilots who
are experienc for 20 years for 30 years
it's impossible to turn a boing jet with
such accuracy first the they give
evidence that how they evidence that
someone spoke from the phone from the
mobile from the plane so what they're
saying in that loose chain that mobile
companies are spending millions of
dollars to let the waves reach at such a
height that the plane is now how is it
possible that the mobile phone could be
heard from such a level and what they
say that the person who spoke on the
mobile he speaks to the mother Mark
binghang so he tells the mother that I
Mark binghang speaking I'm Mark binghang
speaking if I ask to my mother I say I'm
Zak speaking I say I'm Zak speaking so
no son will tell theame to his mother so
this shows that that was again a gimmick
or a planted evidence arm Mark began
speaking and the whole plane is being
sabotaged and we are being taken as
hostage so this shows that this was a
sabotage and furthermore one of the
aerosis saying oh there are buildings
there is water all the AOS know that
building and water is there so these
evidence is shown and furthermore the
plane that crashed into the Pentagon
they said that the CIA is so much well
informed that even the bird cannot fly
over the Pentagon and imagine a plane
comes and crashes into it and the crater
that was created by that plane was round
if a plane crashes into the Pentagon
besides the body of the plane even the
wings will make some dent in the
building there was no evidence of any
Wings found outside the Pentagon it can
be a torpedo which was
sent and several such evidence you can
give a lecture on that I don't intend
doing that so based on this I say that
the evidence shown in loose chain are
far superior than what is shown on BBC
and CNN yet I'm not saying aide job I
said there are possibilities same with
binladin I don't say that binladin is
not a terrorist I said I don't
know I don't say he's a terrorist
neither do I say he's a saint I'm being
neutral seeing the evidence on both the
sides
allaham but the evidence true on the
other side is far superior far more
logical 75 scientist speaking they're
non-muslims they're Americans why should
they speak against the government why
should they speak in favor of Muslims do
you think somebody has bribed them and
here these people 75 scientists they
give a reason why are they blaming
Afghanistan because of oil to have a
pipeline through so they're giving
reasons she say it's a conspiracy theory
I said all conspiracy theories are not
conspiracy it can either be a fact or a
theory so when she says such things a
conspiracy theory which we have heard of
it a lot we have to hear it and then let
our intelligence judge which of the two
is correct if I have to give more
weightage I would give more
weightage to the theory of inside job
yet I'm calling a theory I'm calling it
a fact I'm saying it's a theory yet out
of the two that carries more weight it's
more logical it's more scientific it's
more appealing it exposes the
media but that wasn't given much of
highlight because these media are being
controlled by the governments they been
controlled by wasted interest people so
that is the reason I say that media can
be very dangerous and I've discussed in
detail in my talk media and Islam war of
peace hope that
question Dr Zak few questions and
comments from the websites we have
Roxana perin asking as a world renown
scholar
Dr Zakir should have put certain
conditions before the show he has his
own and best reputation among them I
think he's already answered that but she
says forther comment without certain
conditions he could have just sent his
son would have been the youngest yet
most knowledgeable and more than
sufficient person alone inshah I think
we take that as already
answered we have ajal Rashid who says
okay Arup you're right be that person
person of any religion terrorism should
be condemned in all forms but please
tell me why the specific term Muslim
terrorist is used and not Hindu
terrorist or Christian terrorist or
Zionist
terrorist this was the issue of debate
that day stereotype Zakir started with
the same topic when he was interrupted
one more thing I want to add I'm not
supporting the term Hindu terrorist I'm
just saying Muslim terrorist terminology
should be stopped too Arif Muhammad says
and this debate was only to promote NDTV
and nothing else and indirectly Bara
soall best journalist never allowed
Zakir Nik to speak in fact he was
speaking sense amongst all the nonsense
people sitting there SED Ahmed says
Zakir Nik has never defended Taliban and
alqaeda rather he said he's not sure who
is behind that until he gets the truth
on the note we throw the floor open for
questions from the audience any brother
here yes
brother asalam
alaykum during the show a need was
raised like there should be a
representative or a leader who can uh
speak on behalf of Muslims so how would
you address this
requirement of course they do agree they
should should be a spokesman on behalf
of the Muslims on behalf of Islam but
that spokes person should have knowledge
of Islam should have knowledge of Quran
and say and besides having knowledge of
Quran and say Hadith should also have
knowledge of the media as the Quran
rightly says that Allah says in the
Quran
in 16:43 Andia chapter number 21 vers
number
7 if you don't know ask the person who's
knowledgeable so we should have a
spokesperson who has knowledge on
and and should also have knowledge of
the media because when he's coming on
the media he should know how the media
can twist his words so you should have a
right person who has knowledge of both
so that he can present the media and
this is the only way how the
misconceptions about Islam from the
media can be removed yes any
brother yes brother I would like to ask
why don't you arrange a panel discussion
on P TV
that why don't I have such a panel
discussion on peace TV yes we can have
not that we cannot
have inshallah if Allah Wills but not
such a panel discussion panel discussion
not such a panel discussion such a panel
discussion twisting The View would be un
Islamic even if someone pays me a
million dollar I cannot do it I'm not
here to earn money such a panel
discussion I can't have yes but pel
discussions and we do have we have had
many discussions group discussion we
call same as panel discussion of
Scholars on the peace tv English also
peace TV Udu but we had very few times
that a panel discussion along with
audience this is one of the few ones
that we have but normally when we have a
panel discussion we have a moderator who
is M honest and seed that he gives that
opportunity without cutting the view of
any particular panelist we have had
several I think it's called in the P tv
English Islam under microscope and in
peace TV U it's called
as hope that the question jaak few
comments from the
website F frk says baradat has not given
enough chance to Dr zakar Nik to speak
instead she was asking more to those
people with Shah ruk Khan salii Kabir
Khan who know nothing about Islam and
presenting the wrong picture to all
Muslims for their financial
gains we have Shuma sidiki who says a
useless show Bara did unfair this show
was more for the publicity of my name is
Khan it was just the wastage of the
precious time of Dr Zakir Dr Zakir
should not attend such type of shows
they do not suit him he's mashallah a
great da he should not waste his time on
such useless shows may Allah protect Dr
Zakir from the enemies a mean Ali says
they barely gave Dr Zakir time to
explain facts on Islam the most
knowledgeable of the panelist with the
least amount of air time to discuss
Hindi films stereotyping Muslims it was
obvious they were not interested in
learning how true Islam operates I must
commend Dr NY on the level of patience
he displayed as some of the panelists
tried to give us a watered down version
of Islam and Bara that it was totally
crap and biased
attitude lastly Iran Jamal he says well
after a long sleep I'm just reading all
the comments from where I left yesterday
night I feel that Dr Nik did make up his
point in the very minute time which he
got he quoted the right verses at the
right
time we continue on the
discussion TV talk shows we are
discussing this last TV talk show Dr
Zakir was on here two weeks back on NDTV
We the People program dealing with
stereotyping of Muslims and Muslim
identity uh maybe have our next
questions from the
audience yes
brother
alikum during the show so Alik Khan had
said that she had read the Bible and
parts of the Quran and bhagwad Gita and
then she said that Islam is something
between her and Allah so I just wanted
to ask you whether you agree with her
view or as far as the statement that
Islam is between her and Allah that
Islam is the personal thing between the
human being and Allah that definition
per is correct it is personal it is a
personal relationship but if suppose a
person says that they belong to one
particular religion and if they don't
follow the rules and regulation religion
and yet say that they are belong to that
religion that's the problem so someone
has a personal relationship with
almighty God
that's correct but to say that I am a
Muslim and then I don't follow the rules
of Quran and this is hypocrisy so then I
said say it's personal it's my personal
relationship but I'm not a Muslim to say
I'm a Muslim means I submit my will to
God the will of God is mentioned in the
Quran the Quran say Allah the messenger
so it is
hypocritical but the statement it is
personal that is right but to say it is
personal and then say I'm a Muslim or
then say I'm a Christian and don't
follow the teachings of the Bible you
say I'm a Hindu and don't follow the
teachings of Hinduism of the vas that is
hypocrisy similarly if a person says
he's a Muslim and doesn't follow the
teachings of the Quran and the things of
the Prophet then he should not say he's
a Muslim he says fine I'm proud to be a
non-muslim it's not a problem uh few
comments from the website again we have
brother Muhammad toir who says bar the
whole world could make out how unwilling
you were to give Dr Zakir Nik a chance
to speak you term the show as being
Muslims in today's India and allow the
so-called stars of Bollywood to speak
was it a show of reviewing movies and
are they as important topics concerning
Indian
Muslims Bara to hell with you you have
lost all the credibility Dr Zakir n and
mad Sab should have been given more time
to speak and make others sit and listen
then you all could have understood what
Islam is all about and not the way the
so-called badsha had to explain a
disgusting show andv has to apologize to
both Dr nyak and MN sa for inviting them
and not giving a chance to them to speak
Muhammad Adel says why the hell you
invite a person like Dr Zakir Nik and
then in front of the whole world clearly
do not allow him to complete his point
you think that with this the practicing
Muslim will support the films Stars we
know the reality alhamdulillah just
don't unnecessarily fool the public by
showing such nonsense where every XYZ
starts defining Islam and the real
Scholars are called but not given the
due time to put their views SK says team
NDTV it feels very very sorry you wasted
Dr Zakir nik's precious time and
honestly Bara were you really interested
to know what the Muslim identity is all
about or were you looking out for
glamour goodies the way you were busy
with glamour people out there it seemed
as if asking the sweeper to do the heart
surgery a complete waste rwan Basha says
as expected when Dr NY was trying to say
something Barka said I will come back to
you Zakir but never got back on that
particular
discussion and lastly a question for Dr
Zakir Zakir Nik he is tuned to provide
an explanatory answer on every single
occasion in the discussions like these
you get a focus time of about 15 to 30
seconds if you first give an analogy and
try to explain the real thing by then
the discussion moderator will cut you
short even before the analogy is
complete what remains in the audience
will be the half-told
analogy in this fast food kind of
situation the answers have to be very
quick if it is not possible then don't
take part in this that would be the best
situation it will be a complete waste of
time of people like Dr Zakir his time is
better spent in some other work than
taking part here if you look at shauk he
seems to be a master of these kind of
discussions he has two sentence answers
for almost every question that is posed
if at all something can be done then irf
will inshallah put some effort on coming
up with two sentence answers and then it
will be worth a discussion to watch
there's another brother yav beg who says
as Aman Allah said earlier Dr Zakir must
train himself to respond effectively on
such shows if he wants to go on them
personally I would strongly advise
against it there's a difference between
speaking on a TV channel your own and
speaking in someone else's show I would
strongly advise staying away from
controversial issues as they tend to bog
you down as happened though I must say I
respect Dr Zakir n's courage and the
stand he took not many have the courage
to speak the truth in public Dr zakir's
comments as far as the first questioner
he said that a person should answer in
less than 30 seconds and a person should
be trained and he calls shuk Khan the
person who master in this game I partly
agree partly disagree if you see the
full show Shah ruk Khan was given more
than 11 and a half minutes to speak I
less than three and a half minutes and
many times he spoke more than 1 minute
so to say
that a person should speak in less than
half minute it depends upon the
moderator the moderator gives one person
11 and a half minutes and the other
person less than three and a half
minutes and the questioner is saying
that he was expert that means he hasn't
seen the show properly because shukan
spoke for one one minute one and after
many times because he was not
interrupted secondly I do agree that the
answer should be short it cannot be the
same as you given a lecture I do agree
but even if your answer is short you can
yet manipulate and I gave a simple
example
that if someone ask me that what are
your views about the policies of George
Bush and if I say the policies of George
Bush are not good they will chop off the
not and say that the policies of George
Bush are good so if you cut the knot it
becomes policies are good so this
statement the policies of George Bush
are not good is hardly 10 seconds even
that can be chopped so the person who's
giving the comment I think is not an
expert in the media I do agree it should
be short but if the intention of the
moderator and the intentions of the
producer are not correct are not honest
and if they're evil I'm telling even if
you get the best
expert and since I'm a man of the media
if a best expert comes in front of me
and if I want to put him down by having
evil intentions which I will never do
but if just to show you get me anyone I
will be the moderator I to the post-
production I will make him say what he
does not believe also it's very easy I
know this because I'm a man of the media
not only do I know do I give talks I
know post production I know handling the
camera I do editing mashallah I know
what can be done so what this person is
saying is partly correct but then for a
person to say that a person should be
trained and then come the best trained
person if he comes for a TV talk show
like this and if the moderator has evil
intention
and if the producer is evil intention I
should say should not go on the show so
to say that IR should come with one line
answers we already have that on the
internet we have few second answers we
have got few minutes we have got
lectures of one hour but a person with
evil
intention if he's the moderator or she's
the moderator or the producers it's best
not to go on such a show
or to have your own cameras recording it
or if such thing happens as we received
emails from hundreds of the viewers
expose them so this what we're doing
today is exposing the TRU
exposing what happens behind a talk show
everything what you see on the channel
may not be the
reality jaak Dr Zakir for that candid
comment uh maybe have some more queries
from the audience yes
brother asalam alikum
brother Soha made a comment on the show
saying that majority of the Muslims are
represented by the so-called moderate
Muslims are not practicing and brother
najib also added that they comprise of
almost 99% of them so how important is
uh the
majority and uh do you think uh that it
really reflects or is responsible for
what Islam actually is I disagree with
the comments made by so Ali Khan and
Kabir Khan say 99% not practicing is he
may not he may be if he says he is one
of them I've got no problem but to say
99% are not practicing I totally
disagree on the other hand there may be
many who are not practicing but today
amongst all the religions
though on senses form according to
statistics the religion which has the
maximum following of Christianity has
about more than 2 and a half billion but
according to statistics the religion
which is maximum follow is Islam the
religion which is maximum practice it is
Islam coming to your question does
majority carry of it no if majority says
2 + 2 equal to 3 does 2+ 2 become three
no 2+ 2 will remain four so it is not
the majority which wins it is the H
which
wins so democracy sometime has a problem
in democracy majority says 2 + 2 is
equal to 3 then 2 + 2 becomes three
which is not the case so in Islam
majority doesn't mean the truth wins so
to know about Islam if majority people
say that Muslim means a person living in
Saudi Arabia or a person living in you
know maybe L that doesn't become truth
so majority never wins it is the truth
which wins so to know what is the
definition of Muslim you have to go to
the
dictionary and there you find Muslim
means a person who submits the will to
God so a Muslim is a person who follows
the Commandments of of almighty God and
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad pleas
be yes
brother while the show shuk Khan made a
comment about Salah
that and he believes that I would like
to have your comments on it and the
importance of Salah in Islam oh yes I do
agree that Shah Khan had said that Salah
has to be paid is very important
intention is important if there's no
intention then Salah will be like
astics so I do agree with this therefore
I said many things he said was correct
though he said it that you know Salah is
important but do you
PR so here she even wants to expose
Shan he said it's important to pray but
she asked do you pray and then he said
that I have to admit I don't pray five
times that means when he made a positive
comment about Islam B that goes out of
the way to expose him
and a person says praying is good at
least he's not doing see a person who
says praying is not required then he
becomes a based on the of Muslim that
the difference between IM and kuf is
Salah if a person does not pray and says
it is required to pray he's not a kafir
he's agreeing that it is a f it's
important but he's lacking it he's not
able to do the F so here Shah Khan
agreed that Salah is important and his
statement that Salah is paid with n is
correct but with n and also the way the
prophet showed us so Prophet did say
that n is important same thing with
fasting without Nia the fasting is
useless it will be like
starvation but with also you have to
follow the rules and regulation that you
have to stop eating before the break of
dawn eating and drinking until sunset
similar in Salah besides Nia even the
the postures and described by the
Prophet The Prophet said pray as you see
me pray so Salah is the second pillar of
Islam
after after believing in one God the
second most important pillar that is
Salah why because Salah as I say is a
programming towards
righteousness it keeps you on the right
track and that is the reason it's
mentioned the Quran and several Hadith
that you should pray five times a day
minimum hope question
any questions from the brother yeah yes
brother
Zam this is regarding Kabir Khan he said
that I am a Muslim but I reject all
rituals of Islam but Islam is in my
culture so what's your comment on that
same thing he says I am a Muslim but I
reject the
rituals of Islam so how can he be a
Muslim rituals means the practices
mentioned in the Quran and say had
the person who practices Islam is called
as a Muslim if he rejects the practic of
Islam how can he be called a Muslim he
can be called a sudo Muslim you know
Islam is in my
culture see the culture is different
Muslim culture is different and Islam is
different Islamic culture includes the
rituals if you the Muslim culture
talking about the culture of the country
is different we're talking about Islamic
culture Islamic culture is part of Islam
so he say he doesn't follow the Islamic
rituals but follow the Islamic culture I
don't understand what he's trying to say
is he speaking
English a few comments from our website
we have hasah Rahim who says I found
this program waste of time F salafi says
well it was completely a flop show
wasting a precious time where Dr Zakir
Nik was not given an opportunity to
speak for truth to convince all these
illiterate Muslims as well as
non-muslims shauk and Karan were given
every possible moment to speak for
nothing far aani says the show was more
about shauk Karan rather than Islam
that's funny you ask about Islam to
someone who himself says I don't have
much knowledge about Islam norin Fatima
says I didn't like this program it was
nothing but a waste of time duration of
the program was very limited plus they
invited too many guests Bara didn't give
chance to Dr Zakir think this program
was to discuss movies not Islam I don't
understand why these so-called liberal
Muslims don't simply accept that they
don't have courage to practice Islam
they're interested in worldly benefits
only and lastly
ikuk says what a waste of time Bara was
really not interested in knowing about
the Muslim identity all she was busy was
in cutting off Dr Zakir nik's comments
and not letting him complete his point
of view how sad to see people with so
much knowledge and
education are still illiterate when it
comes to seeking the knowledge of Islam
they are so very confused and very bad
listeners on this may we have some
comments or questions from the audience
yes
brother assalamu
alaykum in this present scenario as we
see that there is so much of media
deceiving and every day there is new
channel that which is coming up by the
non-muslims and they give a biased news
so how important it is for the Muslims
to start their own news channels and
what steps is peace TV and Dr Zakir
personally is taking to start a News
Channel please come I do agree with you
that in the present scenario having a
news channel is very important but you
say what are the Muslims doing for news
channels there are many Muslims which
have news channels but they aren't
Islamic channels there are many Muslims
own news channels but maybe they may be
throwing the same lines as a non-muslims
trying to get a high trp trying to
present what is wanted by the people
rather than presenting the truth so we
have very few or hardly any news channel
which would present the truth even it
would hurt them a person who present the
truth as long as it doesn't hurt them is
an average person a person who presents
falsehood for the benef benefit is a
person who not a good person but the
right person and the Bold person
truthful person is that which will
present the truth even if it hurts the
channels so it require such channels
which speak the truth and which present
what is right as far as starting a news
channel it is there in my agenda when
will it happen allaham Allah knows
whether we do it or somebody else will
come and do it but there's a dire need
of having a channel which speaks the
truth about the media or rather having a
true current affairs Channel I wouldn't
say an Islamic Channel because we have
Islamic channels already what we require
is a true current affairs Channel we
speak the truth and if a Muslim has done
some crime then the Muslim should be
condemned after giving him a fair
hearing that doesn't mean that we should
only praise the Muslims there are
blackship in the community so if that
Muslim has done something wrong Against
Humanity against Islam he should be
condemned but at the same time we should
expose those people who are trying to
tarnish the image of Islam Allah knows
best when and how soon would this
channel come up but we pray to Allah
subhana tala that may help the world
have a true unbiased News Channel so
that the world will come to know what is
actually happening rather than show the
things which will benefit a few
people our audience would uh I'm sure be
interested in this critical comment you
know is
criticizing Dr Zakir for going on this
TV talk show is Dr Javed ibal bat he
writes in a newspaper article on the
topic the problem of being
Nike he says Dr zakir's approach to
debates and discussions is not only
harmful to him but also to his Avid
followers of all the errors made by the
eminent Islamic scholar Dr Zakir Nik
none is perhaps more embarrassing some
tend to replace embarrassing with
serious that his rash decision to enter
into a studio of the NDTV even the
little which he expressed was edited
broken and clipped to fit in with the
scheme of We the People sandwiched
between a temptingly clad soar Ali Khan
and a vice Chancellor of the jamama Mia
islamia he was a ps picture the chapter
this was that heartthrob with phenomenal
Al memory ended up loosening the screws
of his millions of fans next time you
tune in to peace TV a cornard Zakir of
the NDTV would flash in the mind it was
a serious error of judgment because he
was pathetically unprepared he seemed to
have entered to deliver a sermon a
sermon is different from a debate when
everything else is snapped away a sermon
is a monologue one person is permitted
to speak without interruption and
similar comments from Dr Javid uh we
would like Dr Zakir to throw more light
on this critic this is a comment that
was earlier given in Aman somewhat
similar but in a more lighter vein than
Dr Javid that you know you should be
more prepared Etc I'm a man of the media
and giving
talks having lectures having debates is
my profession and I've trained many
people but again what I would like to
say which I said earlier that himself
was contradicting Dr jaid when he says
that Dr zakin Nik he showed a pable
picture and what he spoke was edited so
when he agrees that there is Injustice
done in the editing how can he blame me
so what he should have said that Dr
Zakir Nik did not realize that he would
be edited or something like that would
be much better when he realized that
these things are going to be edited even
if he get an expert as I said earlier
even if he get an expert who's well
vered in answering if the intention of
the moderator and the producer is evil
and unjust and dishonest the exporters
are going to do anything the reason we
appeared as I said we didn't
realize that the producer of the show I
don't know who it is and the moderator
would go to such limits in editing and
not giving an opportunity for me to
speak based on this as is the policy
that I have as far as the viewers are
concerned I thought that would be the
case I
thought but when I downloaded the views
of the fans as I mentioned earlier I
thought what Dr Javid thought that maybe
you know the people would feel very sad
but when I downloaded the views of the
people from the website of NDTV Facebook
and the other websites I realized that
two3 were in my favor it was was rather
exposing B and what you're reading now
everything is there it's not only the
positive one being said even the
negative ones are being said so more
than
two3 have either realized or maybe these
are the people who know the media well
and realize it wasn't given and there
were some who appreciated her the way
she handled not knowing the scenario so
what I say that those people whenever
they see see any TV talk show they
should realize that talk shows per se
they're
manipulative what they do that they
either get a person who has less
knowledge on that subject so if the
topic on Islam they get a person who has
no knowledge about Islam and then he
does the job the moderator need not use
the skills or on the other hand they get
a person who's famous and they cut him
down don't give a proper chance like
what bar did besides all these comment
besides interjecting me for more than 12
times there is a way how a moderator
knows when is the best time to ask a
person if you realized when she started
the show she first asked Shah ruk Khan a
question then she kept on asking other
people she asked me second last or third
last
why because in the beginning of the show
the later you ask the person the better
it is but when she ended the show and
she said now we'll have the final
comments from the panelist the first
person she asked was me why